alors pour analyser cette décision de la
Banque du Canada avec notre Jimmy
janvier ce président économiste en chef
et stratège chez Desjardins merci d'être
là Monsieur Jean est-ce que ça vous a
surpris 1% ce matin on ne semblait pas
s'y attendre du moins pas une hausse
aussi importante non c'est vrai que ça
nous a surprises sauf que en même temps
la logique y était il fallait aller très
vite en territoire neutre donc on est
allé un petit peu plus loin et quand on
met ça qu'on regarde depuis le début
depuis 4 mois on a effectué maintenant
225 points de base de hausse de taux
donc un 25 de plus ou moins quand on
regarde ça pourquoi pas mais c'est quand
même extrêmement rapide et le gouverneur
laissait entendre aujourd'hui quand on
lisante les lignes ça voulait dire je
n'ai pas le choix parce que l'inflation
est déjà très élevé et va encore
s'accélérer en fait on disait 8 % dans
les prochains mois est-ce qu'il y a un
risque réel de spirale inflationniste
oui je pense que
la banque Canada était très inquiète de
son enquête sur les perspectives des
entreprises une enquête auprès des
ménages et des entreprises et qui a
montré une nette augmentation des
anticipations d'inflation donc quand la
Banque du Canada voit ça c'est certain
que elle regarde le risque les gens
décident d'acheter plus parce que ils
ont peur que ça va coûter plus cher de
s'endetter davantage qui va stimuler la
consommation et faire en sorte que
finalement les
l'inflation continue de monter les
augmentations salariales vont se mettre
de la partie on est déjà 7 et demi pour
cent au niveau de la croissance des
salaires au Québec donc tout ça mis
ensemble la Banque du Canada elle dit il
faut mettre un stop à ça et c'est pour
ça que non seulement on a fait ce geste
là mais on a indiqué qu'il y en aura
d'autres
terminé la prochaine réunion d'ailleurs
qui est en septembre cela dit
l'inflation au départ était alimentée en
bonne partie par bon par exemple la
guerre en Ukraine qui a fait bondir les
prix énergie tous les problèmes dans la
chaîne d'approvisionnement mais là on a
senti dans le discours aujourd'hui le
fait que ça s'enracine vraiment et la
crainte que ce soit de longue durée
est-ce que ça vous préoccupe c'est
généralisé c'est un raciné il y a pas de
doute là-dessus maintenant je pense que
dans les prochains mois ce qu'on va
continuer de voir c'est certaines
pressions au niveau des services avec la
réouverture mais en même temps on voit
déjà des signes au niveau des tout ce
qui est mondial par exemple les prix du
pétrole sont en baisse les prix des
métaux on va voir des répercussions sur
le prix des aliments donc on voit un
certain répit j'ai l'impression dans les
prochains mois mais pas assez pour dire
que l'inflation revenue à la cible donc
dans ce contexte là la ferme la Banque
du Canada mais pas juste avant ce canal
a fait aussi aux États-Unis vont devoir
continuer d'être très engagé il y a une
question aussi de crédibilité je pense
que les hausses auto qu'on voit
actuellement c'est pas nécessairement
aujourd'hui qu'elles vont avoir le plein
effet ça va être plus l'année prochaine
mais c'est une question de crédibilité
en matière d'inflation et on sait que ça
aurait été beaucoup remis en question
ces derniers temps donc ce geste là
aussi ce message-là qui est derrière le
geste la Banque du Canada et d'ailleurs
dans le rapport sur la politique
monétaire il y a tout un chapitre à la
fin où on explique pourquoi on a fait
certaines erreurs pour estimer
l'inflation pourquoi on a pas agi plus
tôt est-ce qu'on est en est-ce qu'on est
en mode rattrapage en ce moment il y a
pas de doute là-dessus même pour la
dernière rencontre qui était au mois de
juin nous notre prévision c'était à ce
moment-là de 75 points de base et
lorsque la banane a fait aujourd'hui
signal que finalement c'était elle a
fait erreur elle aurait dû y aller de
manière plus musclée à ce moment-là donc
oui on est en mode rattrapage mais en
même temps se rattrapage là il y a pas
encore il est très bien dit Monsieur
maclem il s'attend pas ce qui est encore
d'autres augmentations de 100 points de
base d'un coup parce qu'il reste qu'on a
une économie on a une des économies les
plus endettées au monde en terme du
secteur et donc on est à un niveau de
taux en ce moment qui est déjà beaucoup
plus élevé que le plafond qu'on avait
été atteint dans le dernier cycle on
s'attend à ce qui est encore 75 points
de base donc ça ça va se répercuter ça
va faire mal c'est l'intention ça
ralentisse les parties de l'économie qui
sont très sensibles comme le marché
immobilier c'est des gens en cours donc
si on y va trop loin on risque de
provoquer une récession qui sera assez
pénètre la crème de la récession on en
entend parler depuis plusieurs semaines
depuis plusieurs mois même maintenant et
lorsqu'on voit un signal comme ça si
fort quand on appuie si fort si
rapidement sur le frein en réduisant
l'accès au crédit est-ce que ce seul
geste là aujourd'hui augmente les
risques d'une récession il y a pas de
doute il faut quand même être conscient
que les économie canadienne étant donné
ça ça dépendance au marché immobilier
dans les dernières années on a pas eu la
purge qu'on a eu aux États-Unis on a pas
eu l'assainissement qu'on a eu après la
grande crise financière au Canada on a
juste vu une accélération constante au
niveau des prix au niveau de
l'endettement donc ça fait en sorte
qu'on est plus vulnérable par la force
des choses l'empreinte du marché
immobilier est plus élevé et le risque
c'est que ça vienne freiner l'emploi à
causer des pertes d'emploi dans des
secteurs qui sont reliés au marché
immobilier que ça se propage ailleurs
dans l'économie donc c'est certain que
avec les hausses de taux il y a un
probabilité qui est plus élevé de voir
une récession probablement autour de
l'année prochaine
ça reste encore à déterminer de manière
précise avec les prochaines données
qu'on va voir mais je dirais que le
risque est quand même assez réel il est
pas négligé
le gouverneur de la Banque du Canada
semblait dire les fondamentaux de
l'économie sont solides on a un commerce
extérieur qui est fort des dépenses des
consommateurs qui sont au rendez-vous
marcher de l'emploi extrêmement
vigoureux également alors selon lui il y
a assez de résilience dans l'économie
canadienne pour qu'on évite une
récession est-ce qu'il a des lunettes
roses monsieur maclem en ce moment on
peut pas le contredire c'est vrai que
les données qu'on a sous la main très
forte mais on est en train d'appliquer
une médecine un remède de cheval
aujourd'hui lorsqu'on a vu et ça se
répercute dans le temps faut pas oublier
la banque du canal la plurimateur c'est
toujours 18 mois 18 à 24 mois avant que
le plein effet se fasse sentir le risque
le danger c'est qu'on calibre mal la
quantité de hausse qui seront
nécessaires à vraiment faire ralentir
l'économie premièrement deuxièmement il
y a aussi l'effet des politiques
monétaires qui se ressent partout pour
juste au Canada ou en zone euro aux
États-Unis et ça on n'est pas en voir ce
que l'on importe aussi dans nos
conditions financières ici donc tout ça
mis ensemble pour faire en sorte qu'il y
ait un surdosage de resserrement et
c'est là-dessus qu'on est on est
particulièrement vulnérable maintenant
il y a des provinces où est-ce qu'il y a
plus de vulnérabilités en Ontario entre
autres ou le marché immobilier il y a eu
des excès il faut le reconnaître en
Colombie Britannique donc ça pourrait
être des une période assez difficile
dans ce coin là ça va être un retour du
balancier qui sera pas évident entre
autres pour les ménages la situation
pour les particuliers d'ailleurs on va y
revenir dans quelques instants Monsieur
Jean merci beaucoup pour vos
explications toujours un plaisir merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]